what is the sum of all even factors of  one thousand to solve this problem note  that one thousand is equal to 10 to the  power of 3 10 is equal to two times five  so the prime factorization of one  thousand is two to the power 3  multiplied by 5 to the power of three  so to calculate all of the factors of  one thousand we must have some factor of  two going from two to the power of zero  to two to the power three multiplied by  some factor of five going from five to  the zero to five to the 3. so we have  this table of all the factors for it to  be an even Factor we must have two to  the one two or three so we can sum up  these twelve numbers conveniently as two  to the one plus two to the two plus two  to the 3 multiplied by the sum of the  powers of five this works out to be two  plus four plus eight multiplied by one  plus five plus twenty five plus one  twenty five which is 14 times 156 and  that gives us the answer of two thousand  one hundred and eighty four